durch wird sagen als nächstes kommen wir
zum mac flori mit cola geschmack etwas
genau bereits bekommen bei einem neuen
video jahre hatte ich hoffe natürlich
ganz gut heute ein wirklich sehr
spontanes view eigentlich sollte gar
kein video kommen aber kommt ja wohl
doch eins und zwei ist mindestens
aufgefallen dass ich schon wirklich sehr
sehr lange kein essens video mehr
gemacht habe und das darf natürlich
nicht passieren da habe ich mir sehr
gerne gemacht und das ist auch immer
echt interessant und es macht spaß und
ihr feiert auch deswegen bauen jetzt so
schlüssel habe ich gefunden
jetzt geht's los leute was ist das
[Applaus]
seit wann ist mein auto grünen
ich verstehe es nicht also ein auto ist
wirklich gerade komplett grün vorne auf
der motorhaube grün hinten grünen an
seiten grün
eigentlich ist er mehr grün als schwarz
jetzt fragt ihr euch sicherlich was
machen wir heute ihr habt zum titel
schon gelesen
es geht heute um neue produkte und zwar
sehr ausgefallene sachen auf die ich
echt gespannt bin ich war nämlich gerade
auf der mcdonald homepage ich war schon
länger nicht für mac ist aber heute wird
sich das ändern zwar gibt es einige neue
sachen zb die kammern br donuts dann
gibt es ein mc sunday cherry cola dann
gibt es einen neuen smoothie und wir
haben ein mcfly popcorn karamell
ja das gibt es jetzt alles und ich werde
es natürlich ausprobieren
diese kamen der donuts sehen so aus ich
weiß nicht ob es gut sehen könnt ich
hoffe mal da bin ich echt mal
aufgespannt deswegen würde ich sagen
will aber gar nicht lange und fahren
einfach mal los und da mal sehen
mal sehen was es wird ich hoffe die
haben auch alles hier weil das gab es
schon ab und zu mal dass es da nicht
alles gab es glaube ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim video ist ein kleiner
blog kleiner essens läuft nichts mehr
aufwändig ist aber ich musste gerade
auch eine menge lernen für klausuren die
anstehen also seid mir nicht böse
achtung so wir sind jetzt hier in der
schlange com mcbride ich wollte mich
immer welche menschen gehen um 16 uhr
jeden ich hab noch nie um 16 uhr im
burger gegessen übrigens habe ich immer
überlegt den mustern grün zumachen
jetzt muss ich den gar nicht mehr gut
machen ohne spaß ich zeige euch gleich
mal von hier aus dem motor aber okay wir
sind dran
es geht nämlich krass
hallo ich hätte gerne einmal die vier
camembert oder 4
das wäre es schon danke noch mal kurz so
leute was mich jetzt sehr positiv
überrascht hat die hatten auch alles ja
das war schon ganz oft nicht so deswegen
freue ich mich jetzt drauf und ich bin
mal gespannt ja ich möchte mich gleich
wenn ich die sachen habe und bis gleich
so leute ich hab jetzt die sachen
eingekauft insgesamt hat das glaube ich
nein eur 47 gekostet ist finde ich für
vier sachen okay aber günstig ist was
anderes
allein hier diese donath eigentlich aber
so damit ich glaube dass das chinesin na
ja klar ich habe mich eben die ganze
zeit was das ist nur dann haben wir hier
noch diesen leckeren drink in schwarz
sieht eigentlich aus wie cola okay und
wir haben ja mal dass kings handeln es
ist nunmal wächserne genau mit kirsch
cola soße und wir haben ein popcorn
macquarie mit popcorn drin da ist halt
wirklich popcorn drin
die idee finde ich an sich scheiße weil
ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen dass
das gut schmeckt aber wir probieren es
natürlich gleich so ich würde sagen
gefangen erstmal wird den donuts ich bin
grad schon hier bei meiner oma und da
hinten die leute gucken dumm weil ich
wahrscheinlich im auto auf dem parkplatz
mit kamera so leute so sieht das ganze
aus sieht aus wie aus dem bilderbuch
schaut euch diesen donath an nicht auf
jeden fall gut und das besondere ist ja
man hat noch diesen tipp dabei das finde
ich eigentlich echt geil und wir
probieren das ganze mal war das ist
wirklich echt geil
ich bin ja wirklich ein käse freuen und
dann auch diesen tipp dazu finde ich
richtig lecker die kombination passt
richtig gut hier wird gute arbeit
geleistet so kaum einer geht noch
ich würde sagen als nächstes kommen wir
zum mac flori mit cola geschmack ja so
gut ich will hier sofort machen
es riecht auf jeden fall auch nach kohle
und schmecken tut wenn
nicht gut das ist überhaupt nicht gut
also den käse sache würde ich wirklich
von eins bis zehn punkten in 19 geben
das jetzt höchstens 3 also das ist gar
nicht lecker die soße passt eigentlich
gar nicht wirklich zu eis hier muss ich
sagen das hätte man besser lösen können
gerne für die nächste kreation einfach
mal meine mails schreiben dann überlege
ich mir da mal was nettes das ist
wirklich kein leckeres eis was wir haben
so kommen wir als nicht bis zum schluss
- runter gefallen so leute wir kommen
als nächstes zum johannes b keine ahnung
was ist genau war smoothie sieht aus wie
kohle habe ich bin mal gespannt wie es
schmeckt ist ein bisschen sauer
also das ist auch nicht mein fall was
habt ihr denn da gemacht da kommen
wieder neue produkte und das ist nur
müll ist ob hier kann man mehr tun hat
also das ist jetzt nicht meins aber ist
natürlich nur mein persönlicher
geschmack also probiert gerne selber mal
vielleicht schmeckt ja mein fall ist es
nicht und wir haben jetzt hier noch das
mcfly wie popcorn edition da weiß ich
auch nicht wer sich so etwas ausdenkt
aber es sieht so aus finde ich dann echt
frech dass man dafür noch irgendwie zwei
euro 70 verlangt zwei euro 79 hat das
glaub ich gekostet ich meine da sind nur
so ein paar popcorn popcorn was ist die
mehrzahl davon da sind wir so ein paar
pro kons drin und karamellsoße und 270
ist natürlich ein sportlicher preis aber
vielleicht steckt ja besonders gut wir
probieren
also ich muss sagen das ist gar nicht
mal so schlecht
bitte nicht gut für die zähne glaube ich
man merkt dem popcorn ist sehr sehr viel
zucker drin
also ich glaube da gibt es für synthes
wie karamell sie schmecken aber
besonders gut das finde ich eigentlich
ganz gut ist natürlich ein bisschen
teuer deswegen gibt's von mir auch nur
sieben punkte aber kann man auf jeden
fall mal probieren jetzt haben wir zwei
sachen die ich ganz cool von zwei sachen
die ich nicht so gut fand und das war
eigentlich auch das heutige video jetzt
mal zu meinen großeltern rein und fragte
wie denen das so schmeckt und heute ab
nächster woche geht es wieder richtig
los mit videos am mittwoch kommt glaube
ich dass nächste genau und bis dahin
will ich sagen
nicht zuviel süßkram es gesund essen ist
das wichtigste nehmt euch ein beispiel
an mir und wir sehen uns mittwoch wieder
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag hat
einen schönen erster mai falls man das
bei euch feiert und yahoo 32